Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now there has been some changes that I will catch you up on,
And I am a little bit peeved because I actually just finished recording an episode
only to discover the horror that is a corrupted recording file
But that doesn't matter, it's okay. (I don't think it is mark.)
I'M NOT MAD ಠ益ಠ.
IT'S FINE ( I don't think it is)
WHATEVER. (Rest in pepperoni headphone users.)
It's fine, its cool, I'm fine, it's whatever.
So what I'm going to do is I'm catch you up
on all of the changes I've made this far and also,
RE-introduce three new members of the locker crew.
First up is urbanstreets who said:
"If your looking for diamond go to where the membrane trees are,
It's kinda risky but it is worth it if you want the laser cutter material.
Just make sure you have a lot of batteries for your sea glide."
(Mark in a cocky voice) Well, urbanstreets, I don't need a sea glide anymore.
I've got a sea moth. I haven't named it bubble butt yet,
But that's because I don't have a moon pool, and that's okay.
Next up is Michael Atlas who said:
"Mark there's a- (rude interruption)Aw shit it's night of course it's night why would anything be agreeable for mehhhh.
He said " there is a big ass temple in one of the islands.
And I actually went to the second Island in the failed episode,
The never before seen episode, and uh I couldn't find any sort of alien temple so,
Unless there is another island somewhere,
I'll show you guys I'm not goofin' ya
So unless there is a new Island somewhere, I have no idea what he is talking about.
But I'll check it out anyway, I'll check it out for you guys,
Because I do have a sea moth and we are going to explore with it.
But next up is, I-Ai-ia- Aiadon gaming who said:
"Good job not cheating. Your subnautica series is much more enjoyable."
So, thank you for joining me, thank you everybody who wrote on the wall,
But also, ahh it's fuacking neihght, okay but also I've got something else that I wan't to show you guys,
It's, Mah bois it's my baby bo- oh fuck.
It's mah baby bois- ah fucking god dammit.
Sorry- hang on wait no don't leave me. I know I left you for like six months,
But I'm A good dad I swear Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall.
It's mah sweet baby bois who i've already put to work. Because they built mah bleh.
They built mah sea moth.
And don't... Ignore the fact that it is broken.
I-a got in a bit of a tizzy,
And I got in a few accidents here and there
kind of got fucked up
don't worry about that that's not
important i am a good sea moth driver
(Inhales) hah so that pretty much catches you up
to everything that I've got but the
other thing that I do have is I do have diamond
i do have the materials
necessary -- well I don't we actually have the
materials necessary but i do have materials
that could be necessary to build the
laser cutter which means that i can go
back into the Aurora and open up the
prawn room and hopefully get a prawn
suit. Now, I don't know if I can do that
just yet but i can get the materials
necessary for the laser cutter so i
gotta find out what the materials are
for laser cutter because I don't fricken'
remember it and I have to drink, im out
of water
fuak I had supplies! I had a bunch and
they're not here anymore because that
stupid and dumb
yeah. okay, so tools! nope tools! I need the
laser cutter which just needs a battery
and titanium which i think i have that? no I
used every last drop I of my, no there is
okay we're okay everything's fine i got
titanium and everything's gonna be
hunky-dory
i also have a battery here dead ones
perfect that is just as good as alive (No it's not)
in my opinion. Yes, so I got everything that
I needed for that and it is night
unfortunately but that's okay because
that's not a deterrent for me but what
is a deterrent is failed recordings and all
i know is that this recording might fail too (Nope)
but either way I'm gonna push the
saltiness out of mah brain because we got
new stuff to explore and we got some
Reaper leviathowns to deteuwr from eating
our faces off and hopefully it's not gonna be
too bad I know I'm running low on water
but I think -- did I hit a fish?
how come I keep getting my freaken' sea moth all
smacked up and I can't stop smacking it
up because i can't stop smacking fish (reaper came out of nowhere)
Hi nice ass ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°). That was a little too close for comfort
also I figured out a way to open up at
this is not important but there was a
little derelict thing that was blown off
the Aurora but i found a way to open up
some (reaper smacking bubblebutt) - god damn it what the fuck we ahh
(reaper jumpscare) fucking fucking fuck YOU fuck you I JUST BUILT THEIS
fuck you (2x) get off get off I hate you fack aff ahhh RUN... DIVE
fuck you god dammit am i ok i'm about
to run out of energy
yeah fak god damn it is going
swimmingly terrible
ahh fuck my sea moth alright well I'm
limped under the ship now don't commit
to me thought I saw something in the
darkness
ok I think I'm okay to think I got a
freaking freaking repair tool here
god dammit this episode is off to a
wonderous start one so happy
hurray. good news guys it's about to
turn day which is good very good
actually
I'm out of energy
I need to replace my god damn Power Cell
ok it okay there we go got Anu on good
thing I got tons of these
I mean he actually really is a good
thing that I got tons of these because
they require a lot of material and I
don't spend time farming up ma power cells
and what's even better about this is as soon as I
find the moonpool plan which I don't
even know where that is anymore but soon
as I find that I'll be able to do
whatever it is i need to do to be able
to charge my sea moth over and over and
over again but first off I need to get
back in this Aurora I need to get things
in order. (groaning noise) It's been a humdinger of day I
know we're not even close to done yet but I'm
going back and why can't I run over one
of those things -- little sacks of shit.
they're better than me huh just cuz you
have stuff and things and a life and
friends and people that love you and
care about you
well I have nothing! All the Reaper
Leviathans that ate up by entire family
Aaaah I'm alone
also it's kind of funny i did find these
logs I don't have much time to look over
them but there was these funny logs that
came by -- oh removed
why was that removed? I don't know. but anyway
it was like "hey the seamoth is a
submersible fast safe mode of transfer
but to continue to meet you recommended
weekly exercise swimming is a fantastic
goal thing for your glutes and
endorphins" and then immediately after
you get in your seamoth it's like
"congratulations survivor you have just
exceeded your weekly exercise caution by
five hundred percent yey
data indicates that swimming was your
favorite activity be sure to vary your
routine for uniform muscle development" -- I
know it's fucking bullshit
and then there was this weird thing I
don't even remember where this was but
it said "detecting massive energy
signature in the region cannot identify"
and I don't know where that was exactly
because i think it was on the way to the
second island but then again on the
island I didn't see anything i'll go
back there and confirm it with you like
I really didn't see anything if like
Michael atlas said there was a big-ass
alien temple on one of the islands and
then I got that message was like oh
maybe there's something on here but I
found absolutely nothing and then this
next one which was little bitch after i
got a diamond that said "remember the
materials together the property of the
Altera corporation. Use of these resources
for survival is sanctioned (approved), but you will be
liable to reimburse the full market
price. Your current bill stands at
$658, 000 credits" -- so it's good news
that as soon as i get rescued
if i do and if I don't die by some sort
of horrible Reaper Leviathan, then i will be put
in massive amounts of debt and then
crippled for life so i might as well
just keep living on this island forever
without my friends and family because
apparently something doesn't want us to
be here anyway so why we even bother
with it. Planet is fuuuuuubernucked -- I mean
plentiful and resources and all that but
the planet is fuuuuubernucked.
(singing a tune) Yoop a doop de de doop doop --
almost got it. almost got it -- bam!
hello it's me....markiplier here...anybody
here
anybody home any data pads ah here we go
what do we got here it is something that I definitely didn't
see "From Huggins to Wilson you're
telling me during his last 13 months you
never took a ride on the outside now
you've got yourself an insider in
robotics will plane we've plain got
nothing to do until we get starside and
start work on the gate you want to get
your hands on with a mech and taste the
Stars you've only got to say I've got a
righteous prawn suit here with your name
on it
you don't know what power feels like
until you've crushed an asteroid with
your bare heavily mechanically augmented
hands."
okay that sounds cool i want that can I
have ooh here we go "Search and rescue crew the
Mongolian vessel Degasi area na--
arm huh
a Mongolian vessel the 'Degasi' disappeared
almost a decade ago
corporate insurance is purchase passage
aboard the Aurora for Emissary Khasar and
your orders are to afford them every
reasonable facility to locate and if
appropriate retrieved the Degasi crew
members without compromising the primary
mission i am allowed to drown ok see
the aurora is due to perform a gravity
slingshot maneuver around plan 4546B
approximately 13 months post launch so
bring the ship within range of the
Degasi last known position. Degasi
crew manifesto has been distributed and
senior employees in a separate data
package so the Degasi was actually the
ship that those people on the the
floating island we're talking about
that's where they are from I believe
anyway i may be mistaken about that but
i'm pretty sure that was their ship and
if so they are all dead and no one will
save them now cuz
I and AND perfect water in this game got
provide my bullshit recording doth noth
but this doth all right what do we got
here ooh I expected this to just keep be
kind of a room okay
oh I need to repair too hah good thing I
got both not just one of the other for
me man
lovely how that magically looks like an
erection but that's okay
haboshky oh nice I like it I like it a lot
I like it alot thats cool I see PRAWN Suits up
there but I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do anything about that
Power Cell perfect i get a lot of those
see a lot of upgrade consoles that's on
fire
am I supposed to be putting this stuff
out can I just dump water on it from
over here that looks almost intact
scan you yes I can I'm gonna get a PRAWN Suit
I mean not this episode I'm gonna get a
PRAWN Suit then I'm gonna finally be
able to mine up those big bunches of
resources that are just taunting me, oh boy (2x)
so there's one more over there and then
i gotta get one of these so i get this
one is a little too on fire this one too on
fire not scannable that's a bunch of
bullshit i thought we lived in 20
whatever century we are in and somehow I
got to be able to get up there
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme it's
right there come on it's right there man
stop such a loser scan it, scan it
c'mon scan it, scan it, ITS RIGHT THERE
ok so maybe he doesn't want me to scan
that one that's ok I didn't need so i
gotta get over this stuff oh hello i do not think
there would be space under here
this looks like something that I could
easily get lost in and then die here I
go anyway
cool action why would they put all this
stuff down here that looks like it's
navigatable unless there was a reason to
do so you know what I mean the reason
oh my god there is oh my god there is
hello
where am whaa hello hi
what is this where am I, oh I didn't get the
last part what is this. Random dewd:"Aurora Tminus 6
minutes
this is an emergency distress court
aurora is on collision course with
planet 4546 (B?)
sending all available environmental day
this 5 survival solution A-L-T-E-R-R-A
HQ T-procedure to any survivors of the
Starship Aurora if you're hearing this
we will do everything in our power to a
rescue mission would take years to reach
you out there but we think we've got a
better solution
A-L-T-E-R-R-A HQ T-procedure we received your Perimental
data and we've sent you a
blueprint for especially design ship we
think will be
the breaking ball that are getting you
back to mirrors transgate
we can get you can find the requisite
materials such we be sure to static
T-Plus 8 hours communications relay
offline" wait
ok that was talking about something the
aurora was going to send data for a ship
that could break orbit like a way to
actually escape is that what i heard
there i'm gonna come back to that in
just a second because I I got a little
sidetracked I didn't get the last prawn
piece but that was really interesting
that was hard to find and i just cut
open a door that I'm gonna go through in
just a little bit but I I just need to
make sure that i'm actually got
everything that i need here before I
start moving on but that's like
fascinating what is that mean for me
though
does that mean I get it or was that a
pre-recorded message for something that
came along before me you know what I
mean it was something about requesting
environmental data but i don't know if i
gave it what it needed or i only
downloaded a message know what I mean
so what's what here that's the big crush
living quarters
god dammit i need one more PRAWN piece if I
can't get a PRAWN piece i'm not going to be
able to build a PRAWN like 3 of, 3 of 4 i think
yeah 3 of 4 so there's gotta be a way to
scan either decent
which I'm think that's true or that one
and maybe that one also on fire which is
also bad so I gotta find a way to go
over here oh whodat bartable i dont need dat vending machine can I do that
can I just get a bunch of food out of
that please I'm desperate
I'm tired of eating living fish
and theres pda over here, let's see
let's see
"including the extras and a counterfeit
operator's license no way the Mongols
gave up the de-restricted data transfuser
for just three thousand it's called
negotiations should have learned in
school didn't move to alterra till I was
16 negotiation class younger it looks
like the Alterra transfuser I have at
home
what do you have if what do you have a
fuser at home for messing around turning
the neighbor's dog blue that kind of
thing
what does your future have these ridges
on the side ridges mean no Alterra
restrictions i heard the Alterra models
more reliable looks better too
are you joking this is the finest
transfuser in the galaxy
I was found a diamond blade on pandora
for less than a thousand that's just
that's barely 250 shy of the altera price still
that saving could have paid for this
trip
what you paid less than 250 i paid
double that ok no idea what they're
supposed to be have no idea why i read
that all but i can get a calm whole
poster
ok man it literally is living quarters
where are all the dead bodies again
whoa bed yes bed bed fucking bed i was
looking for the bed forever the last
time I played this before i did a big
reset before there was a bunch of
updates looking for a fucking bed
well shit dude I don't need a wide bed I
just need an aerobed because I don't
have anybody to sleep with yeay
okay let's see "listen I know I don't have the
right to make demands of you but I need
you to understand that i want to change
our relationship I hear what you're saying
and I will respect it how would you like to
change it i would like to reduce our
contact hours
how much further can we do that to 0
you're dumping me I'm changing the terms
of our relationship is it still a
relationship if we don't see each other
of a kind you have so many expectations
if you just want to spend more time with
those guys on the leisure deck
I feel hostility and what you're saying
and that jealousy is a possessive
emotion i can you be happy for I am
happy for you and I'm happy for the guys
on the laser deck
I'm just not happy for me this is why I
want to change our relationship
Wow Wilson sounds like a dick have no
idea what Wilson was talking about
there is Wilson a robot is that what
we're looking at here as well get a
bench i guess it's got to be coach for
this somewhere then but where I'm not a
hundred percent sure
here that's so bizarre that these things
are just here I don't know how to get em
just yet but I hope to do so soon maybe
there's some more codes like over yonder
way but i still gotta get kind of
freaking scan this last prawn piece
because there are no other prawns
anywhere else in this game at least I
imagine there's not enough i need one
more come on don't leave me hanging
come on be a friend
please ok maybe maybe that was all i
needed over here and maybe I actually do
need to go over this way
oh that's handy thank you for the
flashlight i think that was kind of
guiding my way over this way so there's
gotta be like one more prawn piece over
here its there's just gotta be like
there's no way there isn't because they
wouldn't just leave me hanging with one
laughs so they wanted me to come over
this way and they wanted me to go over
through here
I still don't have the passcode with
this
there's gotta be something else here one
more glorious thing come on, one more, "data
bank corruption was detected in your PDA
your technology Brooklyn's have been
updated" good?
y-yes? what I didn't do anything
what did you give me you didn't give me
shit ah i need supply spare pda's lab next
door to the data coil doors 6483 so
that's probably not this one considering
this one is already open from the other
side but 6483 i do not have a
fire extinguisher, shit, do I, I do okay
is there's something up here that I need
please tell me there is because i want
it so badly
god dammit I don't have a goddamn
propulsion cannon fucking fuck
but this is another way out of here but
I don't have the propulsion cannon I need it
but I mean I can go the other way out
but it would take me fucking forever
ok but 6483 is that the code that
cannot be the code of this one over here
but it could be the code to something
else
what really but it's goddamn open
already
god damn it, it was already open it was a
big hole blasted in the back of it or
maybe that's maybe this was actually
supposed to be locked but for some
reason it was left unlocked
ok but that didn't help me at all
because it didn't give you the data like
anything for my data things, god that's got
to be one more prawn I can scan, there's got
to be, that cannot be, it's got to be
hi oh that was it that was it
yes I couldn't scan through the fire
yes, oh my god I've got the blueprint for
a prawn so i oh my god at all my god
okay so I need aluminum oxide crystal
plasteel ingot Iranian and lubricant
that might be a bit of a bitch but I can
do that I can get the plasteel and I can
get the other things and I can do all
the things that I need to do I just need to
be able to do them ??? (tf mark) ok
so anyway that's all the time again for
this one I do have the prawn suit in the
next episode I'm gonna go get the
materials and build the prawn suit that
I can make that and hopefully utilize
that to navigate the deeper environments
and also gather more resources more
quickly and it should be a lot of fun
and it should be very useful to me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below if you have any
insightful information let me know that
as well, and as always i will see you in
in next video buh-bye (Good ol' outro)